kyle rittenhouse just came out he did an
interview with tucker
and
kyle rittenhouse was asked about his
political views and he shocked a lot of
people and a lot of his supporters when
he said that he supports
black lives matter this case has nothing
to do with race
it never had anything to do with race it
had to do with the right to self-defense
right
i'm not a racist person i support the
blm movement i support peacefully
demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change i
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing to see
how
how much a prosecutor can take advantage
of somebody it's not it's never like
that i love blm i'm a great guy did you
know that the product of usa tag has
been stolen by foreign countries a lot
of times maybe most of the time when you
go to the supermarket and you buy your
meat and you think you're buying
american meat you're not actually buying
american meat so why not just go to the
best source out there
the good ranchers good ranchers have
gone around to great american ranches
found top quality meats they have got
my favorite which are the burgers the
burgers are really good but they've got
fillets they've got all sorts of
different cuts of beef they've got
better than organic chicken head on over
right now to the good ranchers
do not allow labeling laws that favor
foreign countries deprive
american ranchers of your business and
deprive you of good american meat go to
goodranchers.com knowles right now get
10 free beast or filets in addition you
will if you subscribe save 25 off of
each subscription box of mouth-watering
american meats for life the boxes will
show up right on schedule to your door
that is 10 free bistro fillets that's a
119 value free express shipping and 25
dollars off your monthly subscription
for life at goodranchers.com knowles
that is goodranchers.com knowles use
codenoles to check out 10 freebies
truffles
free express shipping 25 bucks off your
monthly subscription for life
goodranchers.com
knowles so
a blm responded and they don't
apparently they're not very welcoming of
kyle rittenhouse they say alexa play i
don't f with you and then they you know
had a bunch of tweets about how terrible
the written house verdict was and how
it's emblematic of white supremacy
well the right here
is giving written house a lot of advice
and a lot of conservatives are saying
kyle you're so mistaken and naive
they're not going to accept you at blm
and blm's a radical marxist organization
and you shouldn't allow yourself with
blm
i i don't really believe that i don't
think that i i believe those uh
criticisms but i don't believe that kyle
rittenhouse actually supports blm he
obviously does not i think kyle
rittenhouse is saying this because he's
about to sue a bunch of media
organizations for for defamation and i
think this helps his case and because
the media organization's acted so
recklessly and irresponsibly he's trying
to make this point very clear but
he's probably just doing it for the the
libel suits here i can't imagine that a
kid with this kind of uh this this
articulate who's just been through all
of this could say in seriousness in
sincerity that he supports
blm i just i just
in 2021 i just don't buy it after blm
torched the country for six months i
don't think so hold up i'm glad you like
that clip ring the bell
ring the bell just subscribe it's very
simple now i know even if you ring the
bell you might not get the notifications
which is why it's very important to head
on over to apple podcasts or spotify or
stitcher or google play or wherever you
listen to podcasts type in the michael
knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you